if China invades Taiwan it's Australia
and the US that got to defend Taiwan now
here's the thing and we haven't had this
discussion we need to talk to y'all
about this a little bit but let's just
be honest right now how confident are we
that we're going to be able to know
who's who right like all right sit the
[__] down let's do
this bro we got into Sydney yesterday
first thing we did off the plane
immediately Bondi
Beach now incredibly excited to go to
bond I've been waiting two years to go
to Bondi Beach not because of like the
natural beauty don't give a
[__] not because of the chicks and the
bikinis don't give a [__] I came to
Australia for one reason because I
wanted to see a full grown Indian
man walk into the ocean with jeans and
socks on okay listen I didn't believe it
was real I did not believe it was a real
thing I'm like this got to be set up at
bonai rescue there's no [__] way
there's no way the Indians Park their
Uber get out in the same
outfit and walk straight into the ocean
and then just [__] float to New
Zealand they don't
even every Indian in New Zealand started
at Bai
Beach is that a cane a seeing eye Kane
you just wait to the front row seat you
blind [__] that is how dare you
bro put him in the back and just tell
him he's in
front he got no clue where he is bro
he's looking at the speaker cuz he
thinks that's
me Australia's been wild man I saw
people protesting Israel Palestine Bo
man that was that was wild bro all these
white Australians out there give them
back their
land
saw these aboriginals on the grass like
what
the D who back there
land we don't even want the land we want
you to increase the center link just
increase the
center and how expensive fuel is I can't
even afford to sniff it anymore
Amsterdam bro diversity this is Moroccan
Moroccans Moroccan
Moroccans Turkish
Moroccans polish
Moroccans if you want to see an actual
Dutchman you got to go to Eric or some
[__] like do we have people from Eric
here now they busy [__] their cousins
back
there
is that true or
what wait is that your version of like
the South like in America okay okay I
just couldn't believe there'd be like a
cousin [__]
place because like you could pay for
[__] so that means you're [__] your
cousin For the Love of the Game bro
like like it's not that you can't get
laid you're like nah that [__] Fine bro
she's she look just like our Grandma I
love that
where are you from bro you're from
Afghanistan okay you know about cousin
[__]
no welcome back
sir what's your background you Indian
gotcha did the post office just close or
something then I [__] come to London
and and I see this [__] stop the oil
protest it was [__] up cuz they throw
the orange paint and there was these
three girls they're like covered with
orange paint I'm like this is [__]
atrocious and I got a little closer they
were just from Liverpool but uh
it's you want to see a girl with real
lips from Liverpool you got to take off
her
[Music]
underwear bro we started out west we
started out in in Perth we got Perth in
the building we got Western Australia in
the building you guys know R everybody
here knows R Island obviously very cool
I wanted more than anything to go check
out the island cuz I wanted to you know
see those adorable little creatures they
got cover in the island I believe you
guys call them the chines
so they're the cutest little things you
can walk right up to them and tickle
them and take a selfie pet them bro
don't feed them though you can't feed
them because they bite and if they bite
you you start buying apartments up in
Sydney it's crazy bro it's so crazy what
happens
bro but there's so many Chinese people
on Rodz Island the quaas are starting to
change bro they don't even smile anymore
they go ha they
coming Chinese are taking over R bro
they don't even call it Rod Island they
call it Taiwan it's it's
[__] that Taiwan [__] is tricky bro I'm
be honest with you because Australia you
know if China invades Taiwan it's
Australia and the US that got to defend
Tom long y'all know that right now
here's the thing and we haven't had this
discussion we need to talk to y'all
about this a little bit but let's just
be honest right now how confident are we
that we're going to be able to know
who's who right like let's
just that's a reasonable question right
once China touches land it's going to be
the Spider-Man mean
night
[Applause]
we going to have to do shirts and skins
for that one y we going to have to do
China you guys will be shirts obviously
cuz that's where they're made
and do you think you could tell a
Taiwanese bro just by looking at it we
need to learn that [__] or come up with
another strategy I don't even want to
tell
y'all I have a strategy the second the
war starts we got to tell every
Taiwanese listen just for this period of
time open them up just just for this
period of
time okay it's like Friday Night Lights
Round Eyes Full Hearts can't lose Okay
you're from Blackpool okay cool nice you
guys kept that name that's what's up
that's not that W people of color pool
that
was where is
Blackpool he just called it the Las
Vegas of the the
north there is no way in [__] hell
black pool is like for like 55-year-old
women that are like celebrating their
last abortion like
that bro the black guy stood up I'm not
talking about you I'm talking about
black pool he got scared he's like pools
I'll drown I need to get me away from
her bro how you going to name a city
after two mortal enemies black people in
water it's like naming a city White
Rhythm listen
we were in Ireland yesterday we got some
Irish
here bro we had a we had we had this Pub
and we had this thing called a spice bag
do you guys know what that
is okay I didn't know that was food I
thought that's what you call Asians
and that's what I'm [__] calling them
from now
on okay I got a [__] hand shot from a
spice back in Thailand turned out he had
a ball back so it was a
little
I come here today I'm asking people I'm
like yo what do you call you know spice
bag is that's something you guys
understand or whatever I go no and I'm
like what do you call like you know
Chinese food or like what do you call
and
uh I didn't think it was possible it
would be more racist and hilarious than
spice
bag I go what do you call it when you go
out for some Chinese food the guy goes
oh we're going out for a
[__] going for a shy
bro only Scottish people can be racist
and Charming at the same [__]
time what do you call it when you go for
an Indian a stinky no guys guys we're
not going to be that racist see we got
some Indians in the front there you go
Indian Scots what do you guys
say what do he say you just said I I
don't know if I can say that one I don't
know I can't say that but I can go out
for a pcka stinky later
so Amsterdam is changing dude last time
I was here y'all had the Black Pete dude
and
now now it's rainbow Pete you done
turned you turn black Pete gay bro how
[__] up is that now there's dudes
going down his chimney that's the most
disrespectful [__]
ever we got to get to the bottom of this
but now they got yellow Pete I saw Asian
Pete a Chinese [__] Peter not only
does he deliver the presentence he he
makes the presentence
god I remember when I first found out
about uh was it schwart pet or something
was that the name of it schwart P yeah I
didn't think it was that bad they were
the guy was describing he was like yeah
basically it's this dude he's with Santa
and he goes down to chimney and because
he's going down to chimney you know he
gets some soot on his face and then
because of that you know he's black in
the face I go yeah that's normal that's
totally I'm like show me a picture of
him I was like is there a black hair
salon in the [__] chimy as well oh we
got Saudi here oh my God man welcome
welcome I know you guys are brothers and
I know everybody you know your your best
friends and everything the Saudis and
the emiratis they love each other they
love as long as they're with each other
they love each other and the second they
leave they're like yeah but they work at
McDonald's we don't do that we don't we
we don't have real jobs they have real
jobs they have a real job working in a
McDonald's we never work in a McDonald's
I'm a minister there are so many
ministers here
bro I I am the minister of air
conditioning minister of air
conditioning let's see if I control all
the air conditioning you want to come
down you want to go up I minister of air
conditioning I am minister of happiness
I minister of
Happiness well not me I get the th
hookers they make the happy
but so when we were in Dubai obviously
we went and saw the birds Khalifa
unbelievable but I heard that when it
was built it wasn't connected to the
sewage system they have like these poop
trucks that have to take the sewage
out and that's why uh you [__] on
hooker's chest
so straight
to long time acting like I was a br get
aart by
[Music]
you bro I couldn't believe it when y'all
brought the Nazi into the [__]
Parliament bro I was crying bro and not
even like a German one you found like a
off
Brands Kirkland Nazi like you got a
Costco Nazi bro you got a dollar store
Nazi [__] was from Ukraine he
wasn't even from Germany he didn't have
to be a Nazi he saw what they were doing
he was like nah these [__]
spitting bro I need to get
down bro he wasn't going to work for
money dude he was going to work for
love
desire passion he was like John tor's
assistant
guys
and I know for a fact you don't have
enough Spanish speakers here cuz
Eglington is still [__] up I just want
to point that out eggington is still
[__] up I did my best to help last
time I did my best I called it
out they're building a [__] Subway is
that it you're building a train why
don't you just cover the top of
it just cover the top of the top is open
right now and I think it's because
Indians you've been lobbying to be able
bble to ride on top of the train
[Music]
and everybody going
surfy is that a
mexic bab my man thank you so much for
coming go fix the [__] streets please
thank you very much thank you that's all
you need you see what I do for your city
I brought Mexicans here and he felt that
there was work that needed to be done he
was like okay I Ain got it I [__] got
him anybody from outside of uh the
country where you from
man East turkistan you know you want to
know something crazy most of us didn't
even know there was a turkistan
so adding the direction was
wild what the [__] is East
Turan is that where the weers are from I
was right about that oh I'm good bro so
wait a minute you're a
weager whoa China get
[Applause]
her or like West China stamp
uh that's crazy man so is it true what's
going on with them
Wagers I don't even really know what's
going
on I just know I'm supposed to tell
China bad bad China
don't do that to those weers over there
but you don't look Chinese at
all cuz you're not Chinese you're from
East
turkistan okay so it's easy to find you
guys you can't
hide yeah that's a tough one I don't
know how to help them I don't know how
to help them bro that's a really tricky
one cuz I do understand yeah cuz if
Taiwan didn't want to fight they could
just be like yo we're on your side and
they be like all right but
you yeah you're
[__] wait do you speak Mandarin or
Cantonese you speak Mandarin wow I wish
you guys could see what she looks like
she just looks
Turkish you look Middle Eastern but if
you were just spitting that Mandarin
that would be so [__] racist sounding
oh my God imagine you walked up on her
speaking to some Chinese people and
she's just going and you're just like
this the most racist girl I've ever seen
in my entire life Abu Dhabi
baby let me understand who's here
obviously we got some locals Make Some
Noise
locals okay everybody who just clapped
isn't wearing underwear how awesome is
that they don't wear underwear under the
candora so if you smell anything guys
this dup by ball sweat we're smelling
dup by ball sweat you know the
confidence that y'all got to have in
wiping your
ass to wear all
white bro if I was wearing all white the
back would look like I was riding a
motorcycle in the
rain okay where are y'all from which
Emirate you're from Dubai oh welcome how
does it feel to be around real
money
soak it up enjoy enjoy
it okay we got Dubai what else we got we
got we got
sha oh we got some chakis here we got
some
Chamis we got some Chamis behave
yourself
chakis I know we got chachis we actually
we don't even have uh the smoke you see
back here we don't have smoke machines
that's five chachis with Vapes on each
side we said go back there chachis and
vape all you
want we need
[Applause]
the I knew there was some chakis here
cuz I was in the parking lot and I saw a
lot of Lexus 430s
so I knew I knew we were going to have a
lot of tarus here today I thought riding
real
low so be careful ladies the chamaki
they're very Charming
ver they'll hit you with the most
Charming thing you could say out here
they'll be like
[Applause]
kti let me take you to the best hotel in
all of Abu
Dhabi it's the back of a Nissan vit it's
the
back n Char is beautiful man Char's got
the biggest library in all of uh the UAE
right yes and one day ladies you will be
able to read the books in there
that instead of just cleaning them so
let's
hope what type of Middle Eastern dog
Palestinian oh
[__] does that exist no I'm
joking I heard a Jew laugh really loud
over there that's you heard that one
[Music]
laugh
a few moments later what type of Asian
are you m what did you just say your
last
name you're from pong is that near
ping oh Mong Mong
huh Mong from what country if you say
Mong I'm going to flip out we don't have
a
country
bro he a say [__] the whole time he
neither do we bro it's okay you'll get
there one day how old are you
guys just just turned 18 yesterday let
me everybody stop let me help you answer
that [__] question again okay do not
ever say just turned
18 again in your
life this guy's trying to get locked up
over here right if she's 18 you go 18 18
and legal don't be like just turn you're
not the [__] brazers title that you
just gave me for her he was proud of
that [__] too wasn't he Steve he's like
just turned 18
yesterday fres as they
come that's like a hamburger from the
crey man let me tell
you so what was it like [__] when she
was
[Applause]
17 don't answer [__] don't
answer goly